el cambio climático es la crisis que
define nuestra época y el desplazamiento
por desastres es una de las
consecuencias más devastadoras del
fenómeno según naciones unidas el cambio
climático causó más desplazados que los
conflictos armados durante 2021 una
situación que europea particularmente
las comunidades más pobres las casas de
recursos naturales o obliga a muchos a
abandonar sus hogares la sequía daña los
cultivos y el frío y la humedad hacen
inhabitables algunos lugares en todo el
mundo para ello entonces salvamos a
nuestro primer imitable es gustado
mañana el coordinador de cambio
climático para américa latina y el
caribe del programa de la onu para el
medio ambiente que seas gustado por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
frança 24 es que según acnur también
cada año más de 20 millones de personas
deben abandonar su hogar y trasladarse a
otros puntos de su propio país debido a
lo que causa la creciente intensidad de
la frecuencia de los eventos climáticos
extremos lluvias inusuales sequías
prolongadas de certificación también
degradación ambiental ciclones mejor
dicho todo lo que estamos viendo en
nuestro tiempo
y podemos hacer y que se está haciendo
digamos actualmente en el mundo para
pues realmente mitigar este cambio
climático y además ayudar estas fisuras
desplazadas por este crisis climática
buenos días muchísimas gracias pues
definitivamente lo que dices es cierto
en el año 2020 tenemos alrededor de 40
millones de nuevos desplazados a nivel
global de los cuales 3 de cada 4 tienen
que ver con desplazamientos causados por
el cambio climático y uno de cada cuatro
tiene que ver con el conflicto con la
violencia no el cambio de digamos de
patear es evidente y bueno pues lo que
podemos hacer obviamente es parar esta
fiebre de emisiones que a pesar de la
pandemia pues ha continuado creciendo
cuando deberíamos estar decreciendo
alrededor de un 7 por ciento
anualmente en todo el mundo estamos
aumentando las emisiones en cerca de un
14% entonces esa es digamos la solución
que va a la raíz del problema mientras
tanto podemos poner parches para mitigar
estos efectos que como decías afectan en
pues en la calidad de vida de las
personas que les hace emigrar
las inundaciones y las sequías esas
tormentas esas plagas no hacen que pues
campesinos alrededor de todo el mundo
tengan que mirar y lo que podemos hacer
es adaptarnos al cambio climático pues
con nuevos cultivos con cultivos
adaptados al clima haciendo una gestión
racional del agua sin embargo todo esto
va a ser como te he dicho antes parches
sí no atacamos el problema que son las
emisiones claro pero hablando digamos de
este problema cuál ha sido la protección
cuál ha sido la atención que han tenido
los gobiernos con estos desplazados
climáticos
mira la atención depende de país por
país es cierto que hay ciertos países
que están más preparados y que son más
conscientes de la problemática existente
por ejemplo me gustaría mencionar en el
caso de la ley de cambio climático del
perú que reconoce
el problema y que establece que se va a
desarrollar un plan de acción para la
emigración forzada debido al cambio
climático bien pero pues es uno de los
países toda la zona andina diría yo es
una de las zonas más afectadas de
nuestra región y con eso
ya hemos desplazamiento de los glaciares
extendiendo hacia atrás se está secando
y población de poblaciones andinas
tienen que ir a bajar a las ciudades
para buscar
posibilidades económicas obra para sacar
la familia adelante entonces hay ciertos
países que sí que lo reconocen que
tienen programas políticas para atajarlo
pero una vez más esto va a ser pan para
hoy y hambre para mañana si no atacamos
la raíz del problema que son las
emisiones pero lamentablemente ha
gustado estas previsiones que nos dan
pues las organizaciones internacionales
y también lo que estamos viendo
actualmente con esta crisis climática
pues no nos da mejores escenarios o todo
parece indicar que no estamos actuando
de la mejor manera posible y todo va a
empeorar qué va a pasar ustedes también
como como ven un escenario futuro a
corto plazo
bueno lo que nos dice este escenario es
que sin la segunda mitad de siglo
seguimos con este mismo patrón de
emisiones prácticamente él
la cifra de desplazados se va a
multiplicar casi por tres no entonces te
puedes imaginar las consecuencias
geopolíticas y económicas de
desestabilización de las economías que
esto va a causar
para nosotros desde naciones unidas-
vemos que la solución técnica existe el
financiamiento por ejemplo para las
energías renovables está demostrado que
es mucho más costo efectivo y bueno lo
estamos viendo ahora mismo con la crisis
de ucrania y la consecuente crisis
energética que estamos viviendo no como
los combustibles fósiles
están desestabilizando nuestro día a día
entonces si las energías renovables son
más baratas y básicamente nos permiten
tener soberanía energética y nos reducen
esa exposición al riesgo y esta gran
variabilidad económica que estamos
viendo con los precios de la energía
la cuestión es que nada hay que parar de
invertir en los fósiles en el petróleo y
el gas y hay que invertir en las
renovables y lo que nos preocupa es ver
que algunos países de américa latina
siguen promoviendo los proyectos y así
fueros proyectos de refinerías etcétera
etcétera cuando la dirección no es esa
también gustavo ya lo estamos viendo con
la guerra en ucrania una crisis
alimentaria que cada vez que se
pronuncia más evidentemente el cambio
climático como lo estamos viendo también
está acabando con los cultivos o con la
ganadería con muchas otras fuentes de
alimentos y producción del campo nos
podríamos enfrentar también a una grave
crisis alimentaria si seguimos como
vamos
efectivamente la crisis alimentaria que
mencionas de ucrania debido a la guerra
pues está ahí
y lo que estamos viendo por ejemplo en
zonas de américa central el triángulo
norte guatemala honduras el salvador es
que cada vez más población está afectada
por el hambre y todo esto es debido a
estas variaciones climáticas que afectan
la productividad agrícola y necesitan
recibir ayuda de emergencia ayuda para
cubrir sus necesidades alimentarias y
definitivamente el cambio climático
solamente va a acelerar este tipo de
procesos